hello everyone this is Amir from Audio
Science Review i've got a new episode for you
one of these trends that started in last
two or three years maybe four years is
building audio files switches network switches
you get two reactions to that anybody in the
computer space immediately says yeah that's
a foolish thing no way an ethernet switch
can make a difference and then you have
the audiophiles at the other extreme
that say oh i put one in my system i made a
knight and a difference and I don't know why but
it you know it made a huge difference so they
must work so you know we could just argue with
words but it's always better to add some data to
the discussion and that's what i set out to do
last year and i think the year before that with a
couple of kind members buying these products and
sending them to me for both objective analysis
and measurements and also for listening tests
so let's switch to that and start our
discussion first let's start with the
plain old ethernet switch gigabit switch
you can buy these eight port ones for
next to nothing 20 bucks if i built an empty
box and shipped it to cost more than 20 these
companies do it manufacture something and
send it out this cheap i don't know but
regardless to say these the technology is heavily
commoditized and it has been for years and years
and years what is a network switch if you're not
a computer guy it basically takes one ethernet
connection and gives you a number extra
one so the put any port can communicate
with any other port and depending on
the throughput you can have concurrent
connections going on so at my desk for example
i have one and lets me connect multiple
product multiple computers and audio
products to one ethernet jack in the wall
a key thing to understand about these products
is that in a home application where the runs are
very short ethernet switches are guaranteed
to be reliable there's you know no chance
for the signal to degrade so much that you drop
packets and what have you and i've got to switch
48-port switch that powers the entire house here
and once every few months i look at the statistics
and absolutely has zero zero data drops now you
could lose packets for other reasons for use wi-fi
you can use a lot of packets but when it comes
to home wiring and the short wires that we use
this is just as guaranteed as
you can get as far as reliability
now from networking point of view we actually have
checks and balances on that in that the standard
protocol or communication language we
use on top of ethernet is called TCP/IP
it's called transmission control protocol
and its job is to provide a point-to-point
communication but also guarantee reliability
and what that means is that it'll send packets
or chunks of data to their receiving system
and once in a while the receiving system
will send what is called an acknowledgement back
saying hey i got that range of data you're good
and until he hears that it actually holds on to
the data and if it never hears that message back
it will actually retransmit the packet and the
receiver then you know if the data has been lost
it gets that back there is another protocol
called UDP that doesn't do that but it's not
a common protocol so when you're browsing the
web the reason is so reliable despite so many
computers and so many flaws that could happen
so many bad things that could happen to your
packets across the internet everything seems
reliable right you're seeing me right now and
you know the texting or youtube windows all
accurate and what have you it's because of
the power of TCP was invented decades and
decades ago and is the foundation of internet
because of that if you take two compute a server
in your home and a client streaming player network
streamer and you play content you're guaranteed
to get a reliable transmission either because
ethernet itself is so robust in a home
environment but also because TCP/IP on top
of that will retransmit if needed now if you use
wi-fi again that's a different story wi-fi is rf
and interference can cause issues there and TCP
again tries to provide reliable communication
but if the data gets lost for long enough time
you'll get your playback will stop and and restart
and but in no case even in that scenario there's a
fidelity reduce you may get buffering where things
start and stop but because TCP is always robust
and always retransmits the final data that you
get is very reliable so actually nobody thought
we needed anything better than that for audio
you know when we're playing something from a NAS
server for example or another computer that has
your files on it or from a streaming service on
the web um once the bits they're all bits they're
digital data that's coming we're not dealing with
analog transmission so the common thinking is that
once that's all the switch needs to do it needs
to get the data and get it to you and reliably
through TCP protocol so why do we need a
audio file switch you know what are these
things supposed to do the standard pitch for these
products is that they want you to think that they
reduce noise and jitter these things make a lot
of sense to a typical audiophile they may not
know what jitter is they may not not even know how
noise gets generated but their intuitive concepts
that noise must be bad and that jitter must be bad
and any device that reduces those two factors must
be a good thing now ethernet just like any other
protocol physical connection physical transport
it's subject to noise and is subject to jitter
but once it captures the data the receiver
from then on the data is digital the concept
of the jitter upstream is gone there is no
such concept anymore because you have digital
bits you can store them in a file the file has
no notion of a noise or jitter it has basically
thrown out whatever problem there was upstream
if that you had too much jitter and you
had too much noise then the data would
have gotten lost and you would have gotten a
glitch and a drop out again that happens with
wi-fi but not with ethernet so but then you know
then are we done do we just you know declare this
you know open and shut case well not quite the
moment you connect the ethernet wire from a switch
to receiving let's say a
streaming device audio device
you don't have a physical connect connection
between the two and in the theoretical world
if that source is noisy because you don't have
this electrical connection that noise can travel
in theory to the receiver and it can bleed
into the sensitive parts of a streamer or a DAC
and pollute this output now ethernet is
designed to be robust against noise so it has
transformer and isolation anyway but let's
say that that stuff doesn't exist that the
cable just comes into the receiver and could
inject noise and jitter and that can't happen
in theory we there are ways for example if i take
a DAC that's not well designed hook it up to USB
the noise and from USB can actually travel
to the output of the DAC even though bits are
bits digital data is reliable yet noise can travel
over ground wires and power wires into the deck so
an audio file that just has this rudimentary
knowledge of how things work will automatically
assume that there must be some merit to
these things so they go out and and try to
you know buy some of these products and let's
start with one of them that's quite popular in the
forums and online a com a company called uptown
audio makes this product called EtherRegen
cost 640 and unlike our product that we were
looking at that was eight ports for 20 bucks
this one's only four ports and cost 640 dollars
so you could buy 30 of the other ones for one of
these so needless to say it's not an economical
solution so it's you know it's got to do some
magic now this is an expensive product for them
to actually build because they've built their
own switch from scratch although they use a SoC
subsystem that already does some of this they
have built enough custom logic around it that if
this did something useful then you could sort of
you know convince yourself maybe it's worth it
although this little hobby box is a giveaway that
you're not buying luxury
goods here going way down to
where it implies that the fidelity is improved is
that it's at the heart of this thing is this low
jitter digital differential digital isolator chips
and ultra-low jitter differential re-clocking
flip-flops now i know what these things mean but
i don't think you need to know what they mean
but an audiophile reading this just immediately
immediately thinks jitters lord and if jitter is
lower then must be that my noise floor is going
down and if my noise floor has gone down maybe
things sound more open maybe less jitter things
sound more analog like which audiophiles like
to think analog is always better than
digital and they run up and purchase this
and hook it up to their system so as i said we
got one of these to evaluate and i tested it one
of the key things here you want to know is that
jitter and noise are extremely easy to measure
so when a company says i've got product x
and it lowers general noise and they don't
show you that the noise and the jitter are
reduced you can immediately write them off
because they must either be incompetent
or they don't even know if this thing
reduces noise in jitter jitter is a variation
in the clock so designers know how to measure
jitter and we can even measure with electronic
audio devices which i'll show you in a minute
so antenna is already up of you know if this
reduces noise and jitter show me you know if
you don't show me then i'm just gonna contest the
claim and that's what happened so this is the box
as you see it's got one port at one end which is
supposed to be is clean ultra clean output then
it's got the other side which is sort of a dirty
side so you plug in your ethernet in here that
comes from your wall and then it's the other side
that's the uber clean but there is also a claim
that these other ports a ports also do something
so i thought well okay we measure everything
um now one of the arguments about these devices is
that if you go tell them they don't work they say
well how good is your system maybe your system's
not resolving enough to see the difference that
this makes so i said fine for my testing i'm going
to use a streamer from company called matrix audio
called matrix i it's a dac with a streaming
functionality built in so it has an ethernet
port and wi-fi it's a thousand dollar DAC
and streamer so not cheap it's not a 10
budget part and it has exceptional performance not
quite the max best of the best that a dac can do
but extremely good as i'll show you in a second
so i plugged this in and first tested the matrix
element i with just my dirty wall ethernet
or cheap ethernet switch that i have
and i'm actually streaming audio to it um from
ROON media player so i'm simulating exactly what
happens in real life you know you have a roon
player or j river what have you UPnP whatever
protocol you're using that's what i'm using so
i'm not using my audio precision to send data
to it i'm actually using a player on a computer
and i'm running roon and i'm pushing data to it
and the data is going over ethernet switch going
to this element i and spitting out analog output
so that's key remember i'm analog it was comes
out of the streamer there is no other output
from a dac if you will it's got audio and that's
the main thing that matters is the audio remember
so we look at SINAD which i talked about before
is a sum of noise and distortion relative to our
signal is 113 db lower than our signal this
is at threshold of hearing which means that
this stream is guaranteed to be transparent
it its distortions are below minus 120 db
that's 5 db better than our hearing threshold and
dynamic range so this streamer what comes out of
it is what's in your music something wrong with
it is something wrong with the music this device
is not contributing anything to it despite
using the dirty ethernet that's going into it
it's producing incredible performance
but maybe it gets better if we use
ether region first let's start with
port a which is their semi-good ports
and run the exact same test do you see anything
different no nothing's different even down to this
little tick over here minus 121 db no difference
whatsoever if there were jitter that would show
up around here if there was noise this would go
up SINAD would reduce this THD plus n would go up
you know voltages are identical 4.05 for 4.053
basically if you breathe on this device that
little one digit changes but essentially there's
no difference whatsoever on the a side of this
switch so let's go to the fancy port hey let's go
to part b that's supposed to make a big difference
what do we see absolutely nothing is still
113 over here still a little better than -1
or 20. 4.05 world one killers clock nothing
has changed absolutely nothing has changed
and remember again i'm measuring what comes
out of the dac and the streaming this is all
that matters because that's what you're going
to listen to right the output of the stream
is going to go to your amplifier and go to
your headphone or to a speaker system that's
what you listen to you don't listen to ethernet
packets right we don't listen to digital data we
don't care what what the box black box doing
upstream its job is to improve this if 640
is supposed to do that and so far 640 hasn't done
us any good whatsoever compared to a 20 option
so let's talk about jitter um the device as i said
claims to reduce jitter but the jitters reducing
is the that of the ethernet jitter and as i said
the data is so reliable there we don't need better
clocks but fine we got that it is possible
to induce jitter in a deck with just noise
so even though you're not mucking with this clock
we can run a test that'll tell us that jitter is
nevertheless induced and i won't talk about the
details of it now maybe i'll do a video on that
but we can measure anything that's happening
to that dac chip that's inside of this streamer
that's done through a standard test we run called
the j-test it's a basically pure 12 kilohertz tone
that we play and then we look at this spectrum of
anything around it okay so this horizontal line
is the noise floor of the deck and every one of
these little ticks is basically an unwanted signal
okay notice the sensitivity of this test it's
at 160 db below the zero which is our signal
remember i said threshold availability is 115 we
are 160 that's how deep we can go we can go 30 40
db past the level that you can possibly ever hear
and when we look there we see a little noise in
here little spike in here minus 140 this could
be a power supply spike or something like that
and these some other ones what they are doesn't
matter what is important is that um i've got the
cheap switch my 20 dollar switch in blue then
i've got the red one is the port b the uber port
on this EtherRegen and look at this the two graphs
land on top of each other where you can't tell one
from the other nothing has happened these little
ticks did not get reduced did not get eliminated
we even have a little tiny bit of jitter a jitter
is always symmetrical it shows up on both sides of
our main tone so there is a tiny bit of jitter
at minus 140 db but the EtherRegen in breadth
eliminate that no look over here it's
still there made no difference whatsoever
all right well are we done i said no let's first
compare port a and port b on this thing because
they claim one is better than the other does poor
and poor DBT make a difference no so even on their
own product the one port that they say is dirtier
than the other they're both extremely good they're
both consistent with the 20 one now people
may say well there might be some RF and some
ultrasonic noise that you're not showing because
the previous test is only goes up to 20 kilohertz
what if there's stuff above it now never mind that
we can't hear the stuff that's above our hearing
range but let's analyze that anyway so we go ahead
and run our j test jitter test again but this time
i expand the band with up to 95 kilohertz so it's
going way way past our hearing range there are
some spurious tones in here and i won't get into
why they are here but again when i go through
just a 20 no-name switch and i go through
this absolutely no difference whatsoever so
nothing's been even high frequency noise is
not being reduced in this somebody may say
well that's not enough maybe there's this rf
stuff that's getting in there there's all this
high frequency stuff that messes everything
up in my audio again remember you don't hear
rf if you could hear rf you go crazy because you
hear the rf from your wi-fi and your cell phone
and everything else you know thank god we can't
hear rf but hey why don't we you know actually
before i tell you that one that's this test well
i'm going to jump into this this then i'll go back
so i went ahead and increased this the analysis
spectrum to over one megahertz and here i'm just
measuring noise okay so i'm not streaming anything
but everything's connected so if the switch no
name switch is injecting noise into my streamer
DAC then i should be able to see it as you see
in here it makes no difference which port i use
whether i use my cheap one or whether i use the
EtherRegen nothing has changed not even a
tiny tiny tiny hair has been moved all the
way up to one megahertz your speakers don't
go up to one megahertz your headphone doesn't
go up to one megahertz not even remotely so
there's absolutely absolutely nothing there
now if i don't go to one meg which is this
previous test i can actually go to extremely low
noise levels so now i have juiced up my audio
precision analyzer where it is now examining
noise levels at minus 160 to minus 180 i mean
this is crazy this is like us trying to hear
noise on the other side of the planet and here's
a noise spectrum no matter which switch you use
it makes no difference whatsoever it just doesn't
we no matter how we skin this cat no matter
whether we look at jitter noise distortion
nothing nothing nothing remotely has changed
um as a side thing this thing cooks you know the
mass market switch has been optimized the heck
so that is very power efficient touch the top of
your switch it will not be worn this little guy
is cooking all along this 640 dollar box
gonna survive i don't know but it's also
wasting this much power just sitting there
cooking itself doing nothing useful for you
now people say well i hook this up and i hear it
why didn't you listen to it well i listened to
it so even though everything in my body says hey
this is not going to make a difference hey you got
to be objective i could have said none of this you
know i could have predicted all those measurements
but we still measure because we want to know so
i went ahead and and set up an interesting test
ethernet and networking is what
we call the asynchronous protocol
when you play audio it's usually a synchronous
protocol meaning the host generates the packets
and the dac meters them out and is playing them
in unison networking is designed to be to not care
about timing when a packet comes from across from
youtube servers to your computer you don't know
indeed on youtube you see a progress bar
usually is ahead of what you're watching
because it tries to pull all the data as fast as
he can just because so that if there is a drop in
throughput all of a sudden he can write that
out and not get a pause and not get a glitch
so we can take advantage of that in that when
we start to play something the streamer is gonna
hoover all those bits and suck them in as much as
he can and store him in his internal buffer and
play so even if we disconnect the ethernet wire
from it it'll continue playing as if the heat is
still coming but one of the cool thing is that
when we disconnect the wire we also disconnect
the source of the noise and jitter right that's
what these audio file switches are supposed to do
so i ran such a test i'm listening to the
music with high quality incredibly high quality
dac and the streamer and headphone system and you
could unplug and plug this ethernet cable as many
times as you want nothing ever happens anybody who
says these things do make it this difference they
should get a loved one to do that unplugging
and plug in and have their backs be against it
and raise their finger when they think there's
been a switch i guarantee you they will all fail
there's just no way no way you'll hear and by
the way that also proves how robust TCP/IP is
that you can disconnect the physical cable and
plug it back in one or two seconds later and it
recovers as if nothing had happened it notices
that the packages are getting lost and it waits
and waits retransmits or transmitting eventually
and it gets through so both in listening tests
and in objective measurements none of this made a
difference should it have made a difference well
no because anybody who designs a streamer that
knows anything about good audio performance will
know that this ethernet data is coming
in it's going to be an ethernet port
it's going to be a CPU it's going to have an
operating system all of that are quite noisy
so a high performance streamer keeps all
that noise isolated from the DAC portion
so that one noise doesn't bleed into the other one
so even if you had the world's noisiest ethernet
connection the designers know that they should
avoid letting that noise bleed into the deck
now someone may say well maybe a cheap
streamer would have this problem my answer is
you buying a 640 dollar network search to fix
a cheap streamer once you get a good streamer
and you don't have this problem and by the way if
that happens why doesn't the manufacturer show and
run the same test go ahead find the jeep streamer
and show me that there's an improvement you won't
be able to because even in extreme cases this is
so isolated so removed from where the business end
of our system is it doesn't make a difference so
with respect to the switch we've tested it we've
listened to it it does nothing nothing nothing
useful other than taking away 640 dollars from you
now this is a low cottage industry
now company after companies figured
out ah all i can all i have to do is take a
some switch and change his power supply and
change his clock and have a little story
i write on a website and i could also be
in business selling a 20 switch for a few hundred
dollars or even a few thousand dollars hey i could
do that so a company called silent angel has a
product called the n8 it's got eight ports on it
and it's revolutionary product it says
makes music more musical and emotional
how do you make an ethernet switch know that to
do that to your music packets what makes what is
emotion when it comes to technical engineering is
there a circuit inside this switch that says oh
this packet of data is music and there's something
wrong with it i've got to make it more musical
so clearly this statement is nonsense but it
follows with what we've talked about which is ah
lower electrical noise and it you know
lowers interference remember again all
of this is upstream of our receiver once we
get the data we don't care about this but hey
that's the story and if you look down here
is the standard story a better clock so lower
jitter lower noise less noise oh medical grade
adapter power supply that must be a good thing
well somebody sent that one to me for testing us
so let's go look at that this one is four hundred
dollars a little bit cheaper not six hundred forty
dollars it definitely looks like a generic switch
so didn't even bother making a fancy switch for a
four hundred dollars fancy case um i'm not gonna
get into the details of this test but you can
this is the standard switch again um same story
did it make a difference through this absolutely
absolutely absolutely not everything is the same
jitter test identical no difference whatsoever
noise floor clean as a whistle no difference
whatsoever now here i did another thing which is
hey let's generate a lot of traffic on the switch
to make it busy so we can generate more noise
and see if that pollutes the output of our deck it
does not a generator basically saturated a gigabit
port piping almost 700 megabits per second which
should never happen see how home continuously
no difference whether you use the cheap switch
or their switch makes no difference whatsoever
so i ran a test in here interesting one so i
basically changing the h changing one to the other
yeah so i've got a i'm streaming through this new
switch and i'm capturing the output and analyzing
its distortion using the audio precision analyzer
i'm plotting that continuously as time goes by
okay while this is happening remember i said
that the streamer buffers a lot of data so i
can disconnect the cable and i can reconnect
it and things keep going so indeed i did that
at times i'm not telling you i did that i
unplugged the ethernet cable the stream i kept
playing and before i could complain and stop i
plug it back in i just connect it plug it back in
you can see in here down to 0.1 decimal
place of noise and distortion you cannot
see any indication whatsoever that the cable was
plugged in or wasn't so if the ethernet cable
brings noise then you should be able
to see its effect the fact that you
can disconnect the cable and connect it and
it absolutely nothing happens in the switch
means that it doesn't matter whatever
noise and the jitter or whatever exists
on ethernet cable does not make its way
all the way out to the output of the deck
listening test again um this time i did it
differently i did it the way an audio file does
he's been using a regular cheap switch those buys
this 400 dollar search drives all excited plugs it
in and listens to it and immediately notices an
improvement there's more detail there's more air
everything sounds more analog like veil's been
removed his system has never ever sounded this
good remarkable incredible guess what when i
listened the exact same thing happened to me
i heard when i plugged in the n8 and the fancy
ethernet switch all those things happened to me
yes it did but here's the catch i
switched the i went from listening to the
audio file switch and went to the cheap generic
switch and the same thing happened again more air
more veil was removed it was more analog
like how is that possible we just saw these
measurements that said that's not possible
am i hearing an improvement the reasons no
when you're paying attention to
what is what your system is doing
your brain switches operations it goes from
lean back join music to becoming an instrument
it's trying to analyze the signal it's trying
to determine whether there's more fidelity
when you focus you start hearing the separation
between notes you start to see through with your
ears the noise floor you start to notice
instruments not because anything's changed
but because you are changing you have changed
you were turned yourself into a instrument
and you're now discovering things just because
you have become different the existing fidelity
has not changed whatsoever it's just like the
Matrix movie with a kid the spoon is bending and
and says it's not spoon that's bending
it's you that's bending that's exactly
what's happened here so this is a pitfall
for audiophiles to go buy tweaks of all kinds
no matter how implausible that tweak is they
perceive it improvement and they do indeed hear it
but it's not the ear that's hearing it it's the
brain that's manufacturing that because it's
analyzing things in different situations than the
old system so i listened i heard what people hear
and i'm here to tell you it is not valid your
listening tests have to be proper when differences
become so small you have to do a blind test get a
loved one put two switches next to each other and
unplug from one plug into the other and plug into
the other one have the loved one do that 10 times
and write down you know your vote you know
which one is which if you get more than eight
out of ten right you're golden but i guarantee
you have no prayer of telling the difference
because there is no difference so long video but
essentially the message here is very very clear
these devices don't fundamentally cannot make a
difference except for very very very very remote
possibility and that remote possibility maybe is
with the junkiest stack streamer you could ever
come up with and if such a product exists
why aren't they not showing it themselves
again anybody who tells you that they can reduce
noise in jitter ask them for noise and gender
measurements you see them in all my measurements
what's wrong with them EtherRegen that company
upton store up and down that they've done their
own measurements and they will come up with it and
will prove us all wrong and that measurement that
the review is a year old nothing came out nothing
ever came out they've made that promise many many
times they're going to write a white paper where's
the white paper where's the measurement nothing
all they talk about is if you look at the signal
on ethernet how it's improved and my answer to
that is simple i don't care how you improve the
ethernet signal i don't listen to the ethernet
signal that's a digital stream a listen to the
output of a DAC and every test that i've shown you
in here is measuring the performance the analog
waveform coming out of the deck that's all i care
about i don't care what's happening inside the
soup that's all those circuits inside i
care about what is the output of the stack
inside of a streamer and if you don't improve
that you don't deserve a penny from okay hopefully
that's been useful um i'll try to do more reviews
and and then sprinkle them here and there with
these debunking videos as people call them thanks
for watching and see you in the next video bye